[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
Гуси, гуси, га-га-га!
Що ти? Стрибала?
Зараз Злата грушок назбирає
і нагодуємо грушками.
Мисочку візьми, ти ж не будеш
дві штучки в оберемку нести.
Займатися неулюбленою справою
нема ніякого резону — треба любити те, що робиш.
Тоді буде успіх.
Ми родина Блонських, проживаємо
на Полтавщині в селі Вовнянка.
Ми займаємося виробництвом крафтових сирів,
розведенням кіз та маємо сироварню.
Груші йдуть.
[російською] Скромно, звісно, але йдуть.
[російською] А кіз називає Злата або тато.
У нас он козлик Бублик є, так?
Злата назвала його чомусь Бубликом.
Це мій улюблений.
[коза мекає]
Ми переїхали з міста Луганськ,
тут проживаємо вже п'ять років.
Працювали в ресторанному бізнесі,
і останні три роки вже займалися фрілансом.
А потім вирішили стати
сироварами і фермерами.
[російською] Он, глянь, яка краса.
[російською] Ой, малюки!
[російською] Ластівки.
[російською] У нас тут маленькі ластівки живуть.
[російською] Ну, ластівки ж поселились,
Владо, і малюки у них з'явилися.
[російською] Звісно ж.
Ми не скиглії. Ми завжди знали,
що треба  розраховувати на себе.
До останнього, так?
Кричав: «Я зі своєї квартири нікуди!»,
але коли у вас над головою
проходить 24 снаряди «Града»,
то вже починаєш замислюватись
про власне життя.
До Марининих батьків поїхали — це північ
Луганської області, підконтрольна Україні територія.
Поїхали, як і всі, до батьків на тиждень.
На тиждень, тоді на місяць.
В травні виїхала Марина, бо була вагітна,
а я приїхав десь через місяць, так?
Через місяць після
тієї ситуації, коли були «Гради».
А тоді вирішили,
що треба все-таки щось шукати,
Златочка народилася, привезли її в Лубни
до бабусі з дідусем показати правнучку
і оскільки вже сюди приїхали, вирішили
подивитися пропозиції з нерухомістю.
Оскільки ми знали, що будемо
займатися виробництвом сирів, —
ферма, господарство, город і т.д —
то вже обирали село.
— Вовнянка виграла завдяки...
— Нормальна хата за такі гроші.
Хоча були плани «хай буде село,
але щоб хоча б садочок, школа були»,
чого тут немає — ні садочка, ні школи.
З інфраструктурою проблематично,
але вирішили, що Миргород недалеко,
машина є, проблем, здається,
не повинно бути.
Найголовніше — всі живі, всі разом.
[російською] Боцік, що ти сховався?
Не дотягуєшся? Виходь сюди!
Виходь сюди!
[російською] Башран! Іди сюди! Що ти ховаєшся?
[російською] Іди!
[російською] А що ти кульгаєш?
[російською] Що ти кульгаєш?
Коза — це така скотина,
яка цілий день має жувати.
Протягом двох годин
наїдається одним кормом.
Якщо хочете, щоб вона давала достатньо молока,
їй треба постійно підсовувати нову їжу.
Ми пішли європейською формою годування:
вони у нас стоять в загоні,
їдять кормовим столом,
і так ми намагаємося балансувати їм харчування.
У тата пальці які чисті. Витер.
Що я тягав? Наче, нічого.
В YouTube можна нарити все, що хочеш.
Першого року я по YouTube місяць
готувався до свого першого окоту.
Я передивився всі можливі варіанти —
все, що може тільки бути.
І вони мені все видали.
[російською] Це все були літня кухня,
відділ для зерна —
[російською] ми це все вжух
і все під цех забрали.
[російською] Погреб і дегустаційний зал
поки що у тестовому режимі.
[російською] Поставили ціль і захотіли собі
зробити, як Злата говорить, будиночок для сиру.
[російською] Так, доцю?
Пікадон, Шабішу —два основних пліснявих сирів
з різними видами плісняви,
з різними витримками.
Козячі, молоді, кажуть, смачні.
Все одно, такий сир,
як ми робимо, не робить ніхто.
Найкращий формат реклами —
це чиясь рекомендація,
не просто чиясь, а рекомендація
близьких, друзів і знайомих.
Як кажуть, БіБіСі спрацювало.
Знаєте, що таке БіБіСі?
Знаєте? Бабуся бабусі сказала.
В принципі, усі працюють
і плюс-мінус, роблять одне і те ж.
[російською] Але отримують різні продукти,
тому на кожен продукт є свій споживач.
[російською] Привчати людей їсти нормальний
якісний продукт на 100 % з молока.
Наразі проблема полягає в тому,
що ми розростаємося.
Знайти персонал — це [проблема,
з якою] ми вже не перший рік боремося.
Село невеличке, вибір невеликий.
Але все-таки помічники є,
роблять, що можуть,
Хто нам ще? Он, помічники ростуть.
Ось головний екскурсовод.
Так, Злато Олександрівно?
[Злата мугикає зі згодою]
Те, що у планах, — зелений туризм.
Хочеться, щоб у людей була можливість
не просто їсти смачний сир,
але й бачити, із чого і як він виробляється.
Фермерство, як і будь-яка справа, за яку ми беремося, —
це можливість самореалізації.
Це село зараз, мабуть,— це вже домівка.
А Україна — це Батьківщина.
Україна має бути отут
[показує на серце] насамперед.
Вовнянка. Хто що каже:
«Що ви придумали? Хто до вас поїде?».
А я кажу, що це всього лише точка на карті.
Треба любити те, що ти робиш.
А де ти це робиш — неважливо:
чи то Луганськ, чи то Вовнянка.
Подобається. Та все подобається.
Свобода і можливість ні від кого не залежати.